A screen reader actually largely
creates the user interface for
the user based on the programatically
expressed semantics.
Instead of a visual UI, the screen
reader provides an auditory interface.
You probably noticed in
the previous exercise
that the screen reader told you some
information about each element.
Roughly speaking,
we can expect some subset of the
following information to be expressed.
What type of element it is?
We call this an elements role.
Sometimes a screen reader might
simply state the element's role.
Other times it might play
an easily recognizable sound
to avoid constant repetition.
Sometimes it might do both.
The screen reader will announce
an elements name, if it has one.
It will announce what its value is,
if it has one.
And it will also announce
any information it
has about an element's state.
So broadly speaking, if we've done
things right, we can expect to hear
information about an element's role,
name, state, and value.